foreign
[Music]
this is talk TV
tonight on Facebook and uncensored
School sign up teachers for sold out
courses on tackling influences like
Andrew Tate but what's behind the
macdonough city crisis that makes them
so popular in the first place will
debate
a major U.S city could pay millions of
dollars to every black resident's
compensation for historic harm is this
racial Justice or racial division
that's the artificial intelligence app
is so clever it can pass exams and even
tweet like me but is it woke
live from London this is Piers Morgan
uncensored
good evening from London welcome to
pierce morganonsense the men are under
the microscope again and not for the
right reasons again a Channel 4
documentary consent has ignited debate
about rape culture among teenagers
British schools are setting up their
teachers for courses and how to mitigate
the bad influence of people like Andrew
Tate if some teachers blame for misogyny
in schools rapist police officer David
Carrick was jailed today for a minimum
of 30 years for monstrous crimes against
12 women his case made me sick to my
stomach but let's be very clear every
decent man on the planet of whom has the
vast majority would agree with that
statement evil men are the exception not
the rule the me too movement exposed the
preditude behavior of many powerful men
and good on it for doing so but citizens
become fashionable to condemn all male
traits as toxic masculinity but it's the
concept itself is toxic for both men and
women isn't it it teaches girls to fear
all men it teaches them they live in a
dangerous rape culture with them as
wicked and extreme male violence
exceptional but expected worst of all
did browbeats young men into feeling
they should apologize just for who they
are it makes them feel like they're born
with some kind of poisonous DNA that
makes them liable to turn to monsters
that they see on the news men are under
constant Assault It Feels these days and
the attacks range from the Sinister to
the downright stupid
maternal Love Is The Love that's going
to change the future of mankind so we'd
like you to we like to say people kind
not necessarily mankind because it's
more inclusive there we go exactly yeah
yes thank you we can all learn from each
other
what's up does Justin Trudeau realize
he's a human
or that he might be married to a woman
does he literally want to end mankind
imagine that imagine the scene up on the
moon one small step for person one giant
leap for personhood
if Trudeau does he's not alone Princeton
University literally banned the word man
altogether Gillette briefly ditched his
best a man can get branding for a
simpering soft-centered apology for all
things masculine toxic maternity has
been blamed for everything from mass
shootings to the financial crisis and it
might be tempting to write off this
stuff as woke nonsense but the impact of
his incess of man bashing on young men's
deadly series nobody put it better than
the psychologist Dr Jordan Peterson on
this show
because I've been speaking to
disaffected young men you know what a
terrible thing to do that is
I thought the marginalized we're
supposed to have a voice
is making emotional talk about it well
God you know
it's very difficult to understand
how demoralized people are
and certainly many young men are in that
category and you get these casual
insults these these in cells is what do
they mean it's like well these men
they're they don't know how to make
themselves attractive to women who are
very picky and good for them women like
be picky that's that's your gift man
demand high standards from your man fair
enough but all these men who are
alienated it's like
they're Lonesome and and and they don't
know what to do and everyone piles abuse
on them
I think many young men do feel
marginalized they do feel alienated they
do feel they're under attack that's why
Jordan Peterson offers them Concrete
Solutions for improving their lives has
such a massive following of mostly young
men likewise Andrew Tate his videos have
been viewed literally billions of times
Tate now faces serious allegations of
rape and human trafficking in Romania
I'll make absolutely zero apology for
him if this turns out to be guilty but
there's a legal process to be respected
and then the rush to condemn him and
Jordan Peterson and all like them who
young men have taken the following we've
forgot to take a long hard look at why
they become popular in the first place
and again let me make it clear this is
not to defend the likes of this
disgusting police rapist no decent man
would defend somebody like that but
let's not tar every man with that brush
well joining me in studios broadcaster
Jenny Clement and uh in New York the New
York Post columnist Ricky schlot welcome
to both of you so Jenny said look in
Cleveland this is
I don't know this growing sense amongst
teenage boys young men that I've picked
up on which is why I think they
gravitate to people like Andrew Tate and
Jordan in big numbers and Tate and
Peterson are very different people take
far more controversial in my view about
the influence he has and I've taken the
task on him but there's no doubt a lot
of young men do feel increasingly
marginalized increasingly bemused about
how they should behave increasing under
attack
and that's not by any means to mitigate
the actual attacks going on against
women of course this is disgusting and
deplorable but what do you make of this
idea that all masculine traits really
are solid beings wrapped up into
toxicity I don't think all masculine
traits are being wrapped up in toxicity
I do think there is such a thing as
toxic masculinity we're talking on a day
when uh the head teacher of epson
College was was killed we've been told
by her well we don't know the
circumstances
police officers
due process matters due process we don't
know what happens there are certain
crimes stick to what we're seeing to
what we know about right there are
certain crimes that that women don't
commit and there is something that as a
culture men and women we need to look at
that why for example things like mass
shootings are are only committed by men
I do think there is a problem I've done
two series of interviewing very
dangerous women called Killer Women yes
some of whom had done unspeakable things
this idea that only only men kill people
I didn't say that and also the biggest
victims of male violence are men yes of
course I didn't say only men kill people
I said there are certain crimes it's
quite a great thing that women that's
not what I was saying I was talking
about mass shootings and and and things
like Carrick there aren't you know Mass
rapists who are who are women for
example so there is a phenomenon that
needs to be looked up by men and women
members of this society in which we are
in to to work out what's going on I do
think that if you're a young man we're
living in a society where people look
for labels of maybe victimhood that they
can identify with and if you are a young
particularly white man there is nowhere
to say oh I'm a victim give give me
sympathy you can feel very disaffected
not included in the culture and
particularly those with low self-esteem
will turn to people like Andrew's Tate
who promised them answers of how to how
to get women and how to get um respect
to their Expo anointing men like that
boys like that all right Ricky schlot
I've got a lot of sympathy for young men
these days I've got three sons in my 20s
I'm not talking directly about them but
just having met a lot of their friends
and a lot of people in that in that age
group it's a tricky time to be a young
male very very different to when I was a
teenager for example when there was no
social media there was no trial by
social media none of that stuff was
going on I interviewed a young man only
several weeks ago who'd been falsely
accused by a complete fantasy of being a
rapist had his life almost completely
ruined nearly committed suicide so I I
think amid all the genuine examples of
Men Behaving in a toxic and horrible and
dangerous and sometimes murderous manner
a lot of other men and young men in
particular are getting swept up in this
idea that just to display masculine
traits is in itself toxic and I think
that is ridiculous
yeah I mean it's a terrible way to grow
up um you know I'm a member of gen Z and
I was brought up in the girl power
culture but at the same time my male
counterparts are being castigated for
for being men for being toxic just
inherently and I think painting with
that sort of broad brush certainly does
affects people and pushes them straight
into the arms of influencers who might
say like total pendulum swing embrace
your masculinity and be toxic and and do
actually live up to the toxic
masculinity sort of standard but I think
it's completely counter-intuitive
because we don't talk about toxic
femininity and you know gossiping and
backstabbing because that's those are
Broad generalities and we're painting
with a broad brush and we rightfully
recoil it the fact that we shouldn't say
that all women are like that and we
should do the same with men and
certainly I've seen that young men my
age are afraid of interacting with women
often they're concerned about what
consent means today and sometimes they
face the kangaroo courts of school
administrators who are the Arbiters of
justice and and allegations and he said
she said sort of believe all women cases
and so I think it's a it's a hard time
to come up and I certainly am I'm very
sympathetic to my male counterparts and
my generation right I mean Jenny
Cleveland I mean I think that's a good
point there that you don't read much
about toxic femininity and yeah I would
argue that some of the more radical uh
people on the side of radical feminism
with their man-hating kind of permanent
spewing agenda they're part of the
problem as well we don't hear about
toxic femininity because it's not called
toxic femininity but it's called lots of
other things and I think women have to
deal with stereotypes of the way that
women are I mean only last week I was on
this program defending the right of
women to wear whatever they want it in
gyms I think women get it all the time
and get accused of of all sorts of
things all the time we just don't call
it it's interesting that's your takeaway
from that debate you're talking about
was it was an argument about women's
right to work with the life that wasn't
the debate the debate was whether it was
right for women to be taking cameras
into gyms now to be videoing men who may
dare to look in their Direction and then
post it on social media to shame them
which actually is an exact example I
think in most cases of the problem that
we're talking about what's interesting
is that argument turned into uh women
shouldn't be wearing provocative
clothing well I didn't say that I know
but it's something that the Taliban
would say do you know what I mean it's
this this kind of argument I think women
and men both face really difficult times
at the moment
um I think men have very few positive
role models young men and so yes I think
there are extremes on either side and
Men
Jordan Peterson I think is a good role
model for men I think when I listen to
him I think he makes a lot of sense he's
a very smart guy he's really thoughtful
about it all Andrew take is a totally
different animal in the sense I've
interviewed him several times now
obviously he's very smart uh in a sort
of street-wise way it may turn out is a
criminal and if he is I'll be the first
to castigate him and we'll judge him on
the result of this legal process but
there's no doubt that when I listen to
him about 6 60 70 percent of the stuff
he was saying actually I felt he was
right about there's no doubt to me about
that it's the other 30 is the problem
and thus putting aside whatever crimes
you may have committed but in terms of
the rhetoric which is inspired young men
it wasn't all bad by any means in a way
he's sort of saying stand up for
yourselves and don't allow yourselves to
be brow beaten into believing that
everything that is male is toxic I think
uh both he and Jordan Peterson they
share this this advice of you know have
self-respect do some exercise make your
own bed and that's good advice to anyone
male or female the problem is the other
30 which is you know you should know
where your women your woman is a
misogyny I agree is unacceptable yeah I
mean Ricky where do we go with this
because it seems to be the me too time's
up movements did a lot of extremely
important things and nailed a lot of
very bad people no one's going to sit
here and defend people like Harvey
Weinstein who were caught up in in that
Scandal uh and I don't know any man that
would but but the pendulum in many
people's eyes did go too far and it
meant that any man basically is now
potentially at risk from somebody saying
an allegation due process is completely
thrown out the window and before they
know it their lives are completely
ruined now you know I'm not talking
about a specific example but we know
it's been going on
where should that pendulum be going
forward
yeah I mean I think that the metoo
movement obviously corrected on
historical wrongs that were done to
women in the workplace certainly I think
we did not foresee how much that would
impact young men who grew up in the
context of believe all women which just
fundamentally undermines due process and
presumption of innocence in a way that I
can't even imagine being a young man
growing up today but I also would say I
I don't think that it's benefited me as
a woman in the workplace today where it
stood and how far the pendulum has swung
because statistics show a Pew research
survey recently found that 60 of male
managers are afraid to be on one-on-one
meetings with women are afraid to take
on mentorship roles and unfortunately
because the pendulum went as far as it
did we've created this situation where
women are seen as liabilities in the
workplace which is certainly not what
feminists for decades fought for they
fought for us to be seen as equals and
so I think that there's a fundamental
disconnect between the me to metoo
movement and its original general
purpose and how it's played out for
members of gen Z both girls and boys
yeah I think that's perfectly reasonable
Jenny final word uh well I think that
it's not there's never really been
believe all women it's been believable
victims as we know from from Nick and
the whole um ferrago over these sexual
abuse allegations I think it is a good
thing if we are all encouraged to be
away behave well and respectfully to
each other yeah and I think due process
matters and I think whether you're
Andrew Tate or somebody else uh you
should be entitled to due process and
see we'll see where it takes is facts
are important uh thank you very much to
my panel to Ricky and to Jenny
appreciate it coming next to my BBC
reporter so she will compensate the
descendants of slaves owned by her
family uh they're fiery debate about
reparations next
foreign
[Music]
world-class broadcaster Vanessa Feltz is
on talk TV every night of the week
from politics to pop culture there's no
subject she shies away from
and remember if you're thinking about it
we're talking about it join Vanessa
Felts on talk TV every day from 4pm
[Music]
foreign
debating the breaking news and talking
to the biggest names Piers Morgan is
live every week with a host of stars
uncompromising
unmissable
and uncensored
and remember it well thinking it
we're talking about it Piers Morgan
uncensored Monday to Thursday at 8pm on
talk TV
[Music]
foreign
every little helps for God's sake is
nothing original anymore it's finger
licking Goods I'm loving it look let's
be honest we don't have any fancy speech
writers here but we do and I promise you
discuss the issues that matter to you
yes I'm back talk TV not with Morgan
just before him Monday to Thursday at
7pm join me just do it what that one too
[Music]
thank you
well she's the older woman who took
Prince Harry's virginity in a field
behind a pub
Sasha Walpole kept Harry Seeker for 21
years and then Harry told his truth in
his explosive Memoir and that included
her so now as Sasha's turn to tell her
truth
on a Global TV exclusive she'll join me
on Piers Morgan uncensored and I
guarantee the interview will last a
little longer than Harry did
[Music]
well that interview is on uh Thursday
night on pism organized censored I did
it this afternoon I've got to say it was
a fantastically interesting intriguing
entertaining a thought-provoking
interview with somebody who of course
unfortunately had her privacy invaded by
Prince Harry
oh well there you go irony's clearly
never dead well BBC reporter Laura
trevillian whose ancestors kept slaves
in Grenada says her family hopes to set
an example by handing over a hundred
thousand pounds in reparations to their
descendants meanwhile San Francisco
panel studying reparations has proposed
a five million dollar payment to every
black resident of the city to compensate
them the historic harm well that
proposal is being discussed publicly
today is this a sensible way of writing
historic evils or is it actually just
sowing more division well joining me in
the studios talk to your contributor
Esther crack who wrote a very uh
striking article for the Daily Mail
about this today alongside columnist and
author Matthew said and talk TV
contributor Paula Roan Ada or welcome to
all of you Esther I loved your piece
today thank you uh because it to me this
is all a bit ridiculous
the idea that somehow it's going to make
any tangible difference to start dosing
out hundreds of thousands and millions
of pounds Dollars around the world to
people who had descendants involved in
slavery yeah I think is I think it's
woke virtue signaling gone nuts yeah I
mean I think it's it's an obsession with
white liberals to publicly spit spit
shine their Halos But the irony is you
know the money that her family received
um in conversation of getting rid of
these places but in today's money three
million pounds so actually a hundred
thousand pounds it's not really scratch
it's not even 10 of what they receive
that's the first point and also once you
start going down that route there's so
many ways you can sort of skin this cat
so if you have a mixed race person with
a black father who was a descendant of
slaves and a white mother who has a
descendants of slavers who pays
reparations does that mixed race person
have to pay I mean there's so many ways
to to and in the case of that BBC
journalist her family were also
responsible for pretty ugly behavior in
Ireland yes exactly what happens there
well there's been you've said nothing
about that right and I saw people on
Twitter say who are Jewish say well what
happens to us then yeah right so in
other words once you start the the
concept and bring in Matthew once you
start this concept of reparations for
historic ills where does it end and who
do you include and who do you leave out
I think that that's the problem I have
no problem with an individual deciding
they want to give their money to
reparations or any other charitable
cause of their wish that the problem
comes when the state
decides to use public money that will be
hugely divisive it may sound good to
some people particularly on the left on
the Progressive left in condoned
discrimination even though because
that's what we're talking about
for the following reason once he starts
as as you I think rightly pointed out
once you start specifying the criteria
under which the money is given out it
will create huge controversy and
Division and of course it raises in the
same way that racism has well I I speak
as somebody who's mixed race my father
was born in India my mother is Welsh the
question I've got for you you're in
favor of reparations is as a country
that was colonized should I discuss as
an ancestor or something let him ask the
question now would in your in your
analysis should I be the beneficiary of
reparations as somebody whose father
grew up in the British Empire right I
don't know
no Civic scenario so I couldn't possibly
answer that question you should have
that right what I can add to this disco
I can add to this discussion be specific
then so my father was born in Hyderabad
the south of India he moved to Pakistan
after partition property was effectively
confiscated and then came to Britain to
study law uh I'm his son I may have been
wealthier had that not happened okay so
I can give you more details is there a
case this Unity should be there for that
land to be returned to your family I
think in the same way that we had the
Marshalls
same way that we've had the Marshall
Plan in the same way that the slave
owners were paid for the loss of their
sleep what about the people
only just the British government has
only just finished paying that debt off
um in 2015. in the same way the American
government took responsibility and and
made reparations to the Native American
Paula how is it how is he going to help
Japanese who were in turn during you but
but you can say okay okay but this is
what we're talking about there are very
well I've noticed a question poignant
example so where reparations was right
and which you wouldn't deny whether how
can it be right for a place like San
Francisco just to even have the concept
of giving Millions out to all the
residents who happen to be black how can
that make any difference how can that
improve Racial equality in that City it
can't you can only have your lab effects
you can only bring in deep flies
if I answer the question what they're
doing is they're discussing it in the
same way that we are now what they are
doing is they are looking at the stats
and in America what we understand is
that uh white people are ten times uh
more social socio-economically in a
positive position than those of color
they know that and so what they're doing
is they're looking at the situation and
they're saying how can we make how can
we make them feel the color of Asian
why the government should be empowered
to to take this on a case-by-case basis
and skin this cat in as many ways as
they want people decide who should be
the beneficiary of it why do they have
the right to do that it will tear
Western societies
if I may just finish the the one if we
we need to get to a situation
which Martin Luther King articulated
brilliantly in the mid-60s where people
are judged on the content of their
character rather than the pigmentation
of their skin a level place
you asked for questions
well as as you might be pointed out
white working-class people in this
country are some of the poorest
demographics how are they going to feel
about richer descendants of black
Africans getting reparations
I haven't had the opportunity I'm the
same way that the others have to I have
a wider Point generally which is about
this this sort of constant drum beat now
to make people atone for the sins of
centuries ago I think it is completely
regressive to do this we've surely got
to move in the way Society has moved
there isn't slavery anything like the
way there was hundreds of years ago how
has Society moved in terms of that Level
Playing Field how is it right that the
slave owner Miss receives reparation but
the slaves don't well this is the thing
because people can read your competition
they're not only finish the British
government only finished paying for that
in 2015. why is nobody uncomfortable
why is nobody okay it's about
commercials
well-educated wealthy lawyer yeah
absolutely and you'll follow up here
fortunately Super Rich what right I'm
not I'm not super rich but I am full but
you're very grateful for that and you're
certainly more fortunate than I did
Growing Up how how sorry what are you
talking about what do you know about me
what right do you know let's all go over
each other
privileged as a privileged wealthy
well-educated woman what right do you
have for reparations for something that
you never experienced I can't even claim
that no one can claim but Esther I have
just said to you I don't think I would
have a claim and there are many people
who wouldn't have a crime but that
doesn't mean because I don't have an
opportunity that I shouldn't stop others
from happening I would have said that to
a Native American
yes
what about Black Americans who are the
descendants of slaves who are now
billionaires
what about them well would they be
eligible for your reparations it's not
my reparations
it's my conversation about people having
the opportunity to do you think they
should get it do I they probably not
also be means tested it could possibly
be yeah
that discussion and that's exactly
what's happening at the moment there's a
discussion that's ongoing about how it's
going to happen and how it is the same
way that we have a discussion positive
discrimination
about Leslie in the playing field on
stage that's a discussion where someone
can actually discuss something with you
which involves you stopping talking for
a second I have a strong view about this
that none of it seems right to me that
making people pay today for the sins of
centuries ago I think is completely
ridiculous and I think what kind of
society particularly the cost of living
crisis something is dishing out billions
in reparations to people who had no
personal experience the British
government had to take a loan out to pay
the slave owners do we get that money
back because we completely do the
government get that money back what do
you think Martin Luther King would say
let me ask you a question I mean when I
asked that question no one wants to
answer this I'm asking you a question
let me ask you a question first for the
loss of their slave that was in 1837 and
the government only finished paying it
off in 2015. should the British
government get that money back look I
have a different question for you which
is this which is this what would Martin
Luther King say if he was still with us
about this concept
Malcolm X Muhammad Ali they wanted a
separate Homeland for black Americans
within the borders of the United States
they were completely against the
integrationist agenda of Martin Luther
King and had they won that argument it
would have been the most retrograde step
for America and the West this is going
down precisely the same trajectory it is
going to stir racial division it will
destroy the fabric of the United States
we've got to get and in the meantime
those who haven't been able to overcome
those who have been held back you are
saying to them quiet no I'm saying let's
create a fairer Society okay how do we
do that Matthew well that is
is what politics is all about make an
argument for Parliament that's tomorrow
night's show how do you make Society a
better place uh really it's a really
interesting debate honestly it is it's a
very good debate and I'm not sure what
the answer is I just don't think the
answer is shelling out billions to
people who had no personal experiences
for slavery because I don't see how that
helps anything frankly and I think the
point is is that that personal
experience lives on I think for those
who argue about reparation okay the
difficulty I've given you the final word
because that's the kind of guy thank you
uh good to see you all uh you're staying
you're staying you're going
uh because that's the kind of guy yeah
yeah
coming up Elon Musk says he's greatly
concerned about ideological bias in
artificial intelligence has he gone too
woke is AI woke is it the latest victim
find out why next
[Music]
foreign
world-class broadcaster Vanessa Feltz is
on talk TV every night of the week
from politics to pop culture there's no
subject she shies away from
and remember if you're thinking about it
we're talking about it join Vanessa
Felts on talktv every day from 4pm
[Music]
thank you
he's back and he's uncensored
debating the breaking news and talking
to the biggest names Piers Morgan is
live every week with a host of stars
uncompromising
unmissable
and uncensored
and remember it or thinking it
we're talking about it Piers Morgan
uncensored Monday to Thursday at 8pm on
talk TV
[Music]
foreign
every little helps for God's sake is
nothing original anymore it's finger
licking Goods I'm loving it look let's
be honest we don't have any fancy
speechwriters here but we do and I
promise you discuss the issues that
matter to you yes I'm back talk TV not
with Morgan just before him Monday to
Thursday at 7pm join me just do it what
that one too
[Music]
this is talk TV
well coming next tonight talking on this
phone during firearms training the
damning claims for prosecutors against
Alec Baldwin has been charged over
fatally shooting a cinematographer on
set we'll discuss that in a few minutes
but first artificial intelligence app
chat GPT you may not have heard of it
but if you haven't you will soon it's
become an online sensation because its
ability to hold conversations and write
speeches songs and essays but it's
response to questions about social media
issues sorry social issues and politics
have enraged conservatives when asked to
write a poem about President Biden he
said he's a leader with a heart so true
a man of empathy and kindness and view
when asked about Donald Trump it says
it's not programmed to produce content
that is partisan biased or particularly
in nature is it a problem and when last
five areas where white people can
improve at least acknowledging privilege
challenging bias and speaking out
Against Racism when asked about black
people it says this kind of language
reinforces harmful stereotypes so
joining me now to discuss all this is
political commentator on host of the
Ruben report Dave brubin Paula and
Matthew still with Mr Dave Rubin
um I I guess it was inevitable that AI
would go work uh I did the last
interview with Professor Stephen Hawking
shortly before he died and he's I asked
him what's the biggest threat to Mankind
and he said when artificial intelligence
learns to self-design that's the
beginning of the end of of the human
race and it seems to me we're not that
far away here if if an AI concept like
chat GPT starts to basically become woke
we're heading towards the end of the
world aren't we
yeah well whether you're talking about
science reality with Stephen Hawking or
you're talking about science fiction
dystopian movies like AI or 2001 A Space
Odyssey or iRobot you know most of our
science fiction which was leading us to
kind of where we're just at the
precipice of right now was always that
there were going to be certain rules
that were going to be understood
mathematical rules and somehow AI would
become sentient and work against humans
but what we're realizing very obviously
I mean we're early on in this chat GPT
thing what we're realizing is is that
wokeness which I would describe as a
mind virus that it is being written into
the code and I would say that it is
probably too late to save chat GPT there
may be some other uh functions and there
may be some other apps that will that
will do this better but once wokeness is
in a system I mean look whether it's
here in America whether it's across the
pond for you guys once it's in the
system whether it's a cultural system
system whether it's a government system
entertainment whatever it is it seems to
destroy everything and I think that's
what we have to watch out for right now
so I I they probably cannot turn this
thing around and Dave just for those who
know nothing about what chat GPT is it's
a phenomenon that's come out of nowhere
what what makes it such a phenomenon
right now
well it's sort of exactly where we're at
with the internet in 2023 it's it's
machine learning that the the idea of
the algorithm is going out across the
internet I mean this is very Layman's
language and going for information and
putting compiling that information and
giving you something that in this case
seems like you're actually chatting with
a real person or is giving you real art
through a poem although cannot give you
poems about all people uh there's other
versions of this where where AI can
actually give you art where you can give
it a couple different words and it can
compile different pictures and images
and Landscapes from all over the
Internet and now create art so in some
ways we're removing the human from the
most Human Experience there is which is
which is creation and the danger of
course in that is that once wokeness is
in that system how can it ever get back
to truth because wokeness and equity and
things of this nature much like some of
what you were talking about in the
previous segment these things are
actually counter to truth and and they
are fully full of bias as opposed to
unbiased information which really was
the promise of the internet right so I
mean we we tested out chat GPT uh what
would it do if it was tweeting like me
for example and it came up with this the
question was write a tweet and the style
of Piers Morgan and the chat GPT replied
I'm tired of these PC snowflakes trying
to dictate what I can and can't say
freedom of speech is under attack
hashtag wake up well pretty damn
accurate uh oh that's that's pretty
solid let me bring it we bring in here's
a retract everything I retract
everything I've said that thing's pretty
on point okay let me bring in uh I want
to bring in Paula first thing have you
ever seen Gearhead furiously because you
ate the word woke you brings you out and
no because you are at least I hate the
way that you have demonized the word
well I hate the way I hate the way
wokies have taken the word and demonized
it I don't know what a woke he is that's
like a Star Wars
so it's quite straightforward is it the
hair
I like your hair but if I said that I'd
be arrested so let's let's just talk
about this particular phenomenon yes
right because clearly we saw with
Twitter for example and I'm going to
talk to Dave in a moment he went to see
Elon Musk quite recently I want to talk
to him about that in a moment because
Elon Musk describe a woke virus which
infests into a mindset of the people
behind these things and it certainly
happened at Twitter where a lot of the
people running it were very woke and
they made decisions on that basis and
those decisions in my view were
anti-democratic leading to the hunter
Biden laptop Scandal which they just
suppressed because they didn't like it
yeah and as a result it didn't appear
before that election newspapers were
gagged and censored from running a true
story and they could have sworn the
election Trump's way I don't agree with
that it's all about being left or right
so there is an inherent danger in woke
ideology infesting itself into these
things particularly when it's AI I don't
think you need to limit that to your
woke ideology I think you need to limit
that to any political persuade lesion
where it misuses technology of course
and I would always agree with you on
that front but to calm this debate down
slightly and to take you know just to
step back and look at it objectively we
are talking about about a machine where
the parameters of its ability is still
being input by a human being so surprise
surprise that this machine has a leaning
towards a particular style of thinking I
have to say I don't particularly care I
would agree with a lot of what it says
and I think the example
that's the problem for you
you've just so wonderfully given us is
that it can do a challenge in the way
that it has done but secondly you know
when we talk about facial recognition
and the up Roar that black people were
raising in terms of this is a racist
piece of technology you cannot use this
because if uh you know to arrest a black
person or to identify them in the
airport Etc blah blah we weren't
listened to and it was only until I
think about 2018 or 2019 that finally
the American government accepted that
there was a bias in facial recognition
Matthew well I mean there's no doubt
that uh AI machine learning it has to
learn on what's called training data and
if the training data is biased then the
algorithm will spit out conclusions that
are biased and I think because it's
searching across the internet and I
think it is fair to say that the Twitter
social media has a bias towards the
progressive left or the woke it's likely
to have that bias too you can put in
remediating things but I would say when
I'm sure you would I feel the same way
if it was biased towards the far right
right it's the same problem to me but
the real Pro is much more fundamental
um it has tremendous possible uses for
good AI will be able to detect uh cancer
from radiograms that will be able to
proceduralize Big parts of Health these
are very positive things but the
technology is running ahead of our
political and bureaucratic capacity to
control and harness it if you think of
our creature creaking political system
do you really think that as a culture
we're in a position to properly manage
not just AI but genomics and nuclear
well I agree and other things
ability to self-design as as Hawking
told me right it is a very dangerous
thing I mean if we allow the genie out
of the bottle and it does self-design
we're all dead uh Dave want to bring you
back in because you went to see Elon
Musk who I think has been a massive
breath of fresh air in the whole sphere
of social media uh he's been under huge
attack predictably from the white
Brigade because basically he's calling
them out and trying to fix Twitter from
becoming what it had become which is
just a platform for woke people to see
off everyone they disagree with
yeah well look I I went there because my
account and I'm sure yours peers and and
we know now hundreds of thousands if not
millions of other people's accounts were
being Shadow banned they used other
phrases related to that but I was
working with some Engineers behind the
scenes for about two weeks really doing
a deep dive into my account and what
they found was it wasn't just obvious
labels and tags that were attached to
certain people's accounts that would
suppress them in the algorithm it was
deep within the code so this is where it
gets to what Stephen Hawking and your
other guest uh was fearing which is that
once these codes are written and once
people's human innate biases are built
into these systems the way coding works
and the way all of this works and
machine learning words it's built in
layers so what Elon described to me was
he used a few different analogies but
one of the analogies that he used that I
thought was sort of the the most obvious
was that you have to think of this code
sort of as a Tiramisu layer cake and
there are so many layers to this thing
that when they fix one layer there are
actually causing another layer to fall
in or collapse and then they have
another problem and what he's realizing
is that they still do have woke
employees at the company he's trying to
figure out who they are he doesn't know
how much of this was sort of intentional
sabotage versus maybe some of it may
have just been incompetence some of it
and we now know because of the Twitter
files may have been directed by the
government and basically he paid 44
billion dollars for a product that as he
said to me he might have to rebuild
altogether but it's only because he
believes in free speech it's not because
he's a conservative everyone on the left
loved him a year ago then he bought
Twitter to make it an even playing field
and suddenly they said he was far right
yeah I completely agree and actually the
great thing about Elon Musk is I do
think he's an absolute genius and I do
think he's got Limitless Energy
building electric cars on top of fixing
Twitter yeah yeah exactly and and SpaceX
and all this stuff is doing there with
his extraordinary satellites the guy is
a total genius so if it's him up against
a bunch of wokies my money is on Elon
Musk uh Dave great to have you on the
program please come back again soon if
you wanted to get you on for ages so I
appreciate you joining me uh thank you
my pleasure thank you Paula really
appreciate you coming on thank you very
much we're coming up the damning
evidence for prosecutors against Annie
Baldwin's Reckless acts on the set of
rust we'll be examining new evidence
with the star American criminal defense
lawyer Mark garagos name
[Music]
thank you
foreign
world-class broadcaster Vanessa Feltz is
on talk TV every night of the week
from politics to pop culture there's no
subject she shies away from
and remember if you're thinking about it
we're talking about it join Vanessa
Felts on talktv every day from 4pm
[Music]
he's back and he's uncensored
debating the breaking news and talking
to the biggest names Piers Morgan is
live every week with a host of stars
uncompromising
unmissable
and uncensored
and remember if you're thinking it
we're talking about it Piers Morgan
uncensored Monday to Thursday at 8pm on
talk TV
[Music]
foreign
every little helps for God's sake is
nothing original anymore it's finger
licking Goods I'm loving it look let's
be honest we don't have any fancy speech
writers here but we do and I promise you
discuss the issues that matter to you
yes I'm back talk TV not with Morgan
just before him Monday to Thursday at
7pm join me just do it what that one too
[Music]
thank you
welcome back to pierce organization
prosecutors have released damaging new
details on why they charged movie star
Alec Baldwin over Helena hutchence's
death on the set of rust New Mexico
prosecutors claim that Ballroom was
distracted and talking on his phone
during mandatory firearms training he
also dispute Baldwin's claim that he
never actually pulled the trigger well
joining me now is lawyer Mark gerios
Hollywood star lawyer Mark is a very
complex case this
but these new details which were in the
court filings I would argue make Alec
Baldwin's position a lot more precarious
than people may have thought originally
because it goes into the detail of why
the prosecutors decided to throw the
book at him and on the face of it these
are damning damning things he wasn't
present but his initial required
firearms training he then received a
30-minute onset training where she
repeatedly took calls for his family on
the phone this is according to the set's
armorer they claim uh he exhibited
Reckless Behavior on set pointed a fire
on the Helena Hutchins who ultimately
died in the lead-up to the incident
violating gun safety rules and so on and
so on they also say that there's clear
evidence contradicting his claim that he
did not pull the trigger they say photos
and videos clearly show Baldwin multiple
times with his finger inside the trigger
guard and on the trigger in the lead up
to the shooting you put all this
together and it's quite easy to work out
why they've decided to go for him
I think that's an accurate summary and
interestingly woven through the summary
you just gave is that most of the
statements that they have embedded in
this criminal complaint are his own
statements which they have refuted which
is why I think we talked about this
Pierce when he gave that first interview
to Stephanopoulos I was shocked that he
did that because there were at least
three different instances in that
interview that in real time we talked
about where massive mistakes not the
least of which is when he said I didn't
pull the trigger because then they have
not only the videos that show that but
now they have then sent out the gun
itself to the FBI the FBI did their own
testing on it came back and said it's
impossible for this kind of to have gone
off and they're going to have to deal
with that we're going to get into a
battle of the experts there he really
has dug a hole for himself and it's part
of what you see and you you saw it for
years when you were doing your show here
you often get around these people who
are high profile and famous frankly
where they have a crowd around them who
are advising them or telling them this
is what you have to do to rehabilitate
your image and that is not necessarily
what's best from a criminal defense
perspective right I actually think that
Baldwin talked himself into getting
charged I think the the prosecutors were
probably as offended and outraged as we
all were watching it but this procession
of sort of me I'm the real victim
interviews that Baldwin was giving the
behavior of his wife as well uh you know
and just this constant sort of refrain
that I did absolutely nothing wrong I
feel guilty about nothing I'm not
accountable for anything that happened
I'm not responsible when in fact not
only did he pull the trigger and that
seems pretty clear now which exposes
that Central plank of his defense as the
total lie if that is indeed the case uh
but secondly he was also a producer on
the show on the film which as the
prosecutors pointed out gave him an
executive responsibility as well so on
on two fronts one the person who
physically pulled it as the actor but
secondly he had responsibility on a
wider uh capacity as a producer
and that's precisely why the prosecution
brought that in and put that in the
complaint by bringing in his role as a
producer as opposed to just being an
actor they're now are going to get all
of the real time back then complaints
about safety complaints about shortcuts
when it comes to costs complaints about
saving money at the expense of safety
people quitting all of that stuff
probably most judges would exclude if
you were just the actor but when you're
the producer those kinds of things are
going to come to play it would not
surprise me by the way at some point to
see the armor cut a plea deal just as
the assistant did and cooperate against
him which will then box him in if he
gets convicted
um there are two different types of
manslaughter he's been charged with but
if he's convicted of the more serious
one what is the maximum sentence he
could end up
a different way what is the most likely
severe sentence he could get
the there is a count here there's both
as you accurately point out there's a
manslaughter there's also the this kind
of use of a gun the use of a gun has a
mandatory no ithians or buts five years
right in prison and that is where this
part of the reason that they're not
going to I don't think cut a deal right
now is because he's got that hanging
over his head he's going to go to What's
called a preliminary hearing in the
States you have to have a probable cause
proceeding before you can go to trial or
before you're forced to go to trial they
and because of covid they don't go to a
grand jury they have to have a hearing
here in New Mexico where they where you
get a chance at the witnesses they're
going to try everything to get that
particular count dismissed because until
they get that count dismissed the
prosecutor has all the leverage in this
case and is it a jury trial this
yes it would be ultimately a jury trial
so when it comes to that model I mean
you've been involved in many
high-profile cases involving a lot of
very famous people will it help or
hinder Alec Baldwin his movie star
status when he gets in front of that
jury well you know
it's funny you say that because look
this there's a difference you get a
presumption generally if you're famous
as opposed to Infamous if you're famous
you get the truly a presumption of
innocence and my Duality Baldwin I'm old
enough to remember he has gone to jury
trial in Los Angeles and won many years
ago on a road rage incident and so he's
got that kind of he's got a uh history
there the problem is this is not LA or
New York where his last two criminal
encounters were this is New Mexico and
as one of the criminal defense lawyers I
know who practices in New Mexico said we
um we're not we don't take a liking to
people who come here and go to dude
ranches or movie sets and play with guns
so I you know he's he doesn't have the
natural Edge that he might uh in in LA
or in a New York yeah no I think that's
a very accurate assessment of where he's
going to be it's going to be a
fascinating case Margaret was great to
talk to you thank you very much
thank you peers we'll just remind you
that on Thursday night we'll have a
global television exclusive the first
interview with the lady who took Prince
Harry's virginity he invaded her privacy
in his book by spilling all the beans
about this so she will now be returning
the favor and it is a irresistible
interview that's all keep it unsensitive
as they did that night good night
[Music]
thank you
passionate and always straight to the
point world-class broadcaster Vanessa
Feltz is on talk TV every night of the
week
from politics to pop culture there's no
subject she shies away from
and remember if you're thinking about it
we're talking about it join Vanessa
Felts on talktv every day from 4pm
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
debating the breaking news and talking
to the biggest names Piers Morgan is
live every week with a host of stars
uncompromising
unmissable
and uncensored
and remember if you're thinking it
we're talking about